[Music]
foreign
frequently discussed the trials and
tribulations faced by parents who seek
tolerable entertainment options for
their children really we would prefer
something wholesome and enriching but
that very often proves to be too high a
bar so we'll settle for tolerable which
simply means that it's a children's show
or film that doesn't engage in left-wing
brainwashing and isn't so loud stupid
and obnoxious that we can't stand to be
in the room when it's on this is a bar
high enough that 99 of all modern
Children's Entertainment cannot hope to
clear it and it whittles the options
down considerably so that we can um you
know we could feel pretty safe with
whatever few options are left
and one of the options left is a show
that listeners of this podcast first
alerted me to it's um it not only it not
only clears the not woke not obnoxious
bar but even manages the extremely rare
feat of hurtling the actively wholesome
and enriching bar which is way up here
Bluey is a cartoon originally out of
Australia about a family of blue heeler
dogs blue herself the older daughter in
the family is the main character but
most episodes prominently feature her
family members her younger sister her
mom and her dad and the dad is named
Bandit in the show probably the show's
most beloved character and the show is
uh is funny it's entertaining it's
clever
and although the characters are
anthropomorphic animals the family
Dynamics are you know pretty realistic
and and also positive the dad character
especially is a source of Comedy
um which for most modern entertainment
would mean that he's a stupid bumbling
oaf and the butt of all the jokes but
that's not the case in the show Bandit
is portrayed as an attentive and engaged
father who leads a happy cartoon family
uh the show is not a work of towering
artistic genius probably not gonna be
the kind of thing that people are
studying and talking about 500 years
from now that's fine it's it's just a
it's a wholesome children show it's fine
it's good it's normal
and that's why the woke crowd is
absolutely determined to ruin it
back in so let's trace this uh the
history of the the woe crowd going after
Bluey
um it's been a long campaign a long
battle they've been waging back in 2021
there's a journalist named Beverly Wang
wrote an article for ABC which is the
Australian Broadcasting Company in this
case
and she applauded the show for being as
she says tender nuanced and joyful and
yet at the same time she criticized it
for its lack of representation an
article that's um
I'm 99 sure isn't supposed to be satire
Wang wrote quote as a parent of color I
am always conscious of the presence or
absence of diverse representation in
kids pop culture what it means for
children the conversations we have
around that I sincerely believe you
don't have to be other to think about
this too we live in a world where the
majority of main characters on
children's television are white where
there are more animals than people of
color protagonists populating the pages
of children's books where are the
disabled queer poor gender diverse dogs
of color and single parent dog families
in blues Brisbane if they're in the
background well let them come forward
now the most obvious answer here is that
the show does feature dogs of color the
color is blue hence the name of the show
does it over represent the blue colored
Community does it make blue people feel
more welcome and included at the expense
of authorizing those in the audience who
might be you know pink or green or
purple or some other color perhaps
but these seem like minor complaints
does the show fail to include queer and
quote gender diverse dogs whatever that
means again yes that's because the
makers of Bluey
um you know made the the the provocative
decision to not turn the show into a
vehicle for sexual indoctrination and
thank God for that
as to the lack of poor dogs and
single-parent family dogs and disabled
dogs and dogs with hearing difficulties
and dogs with ADHD and dogs with food
allergies and illegal immigrant dogs
dogs with sleep apnea dogs with eczema
Etc these boxes are not checked but
that's because the show is not trying to
check boxes it's just trying to tell a
story a very simple story to Children
given that none of the children in the
audience are dogs and none of them have
dog parents none of them will feel
represented in the extremely literal way
that the left demands
but that's a good thing because
worthwhile Children's Entertainment is
supposed to activate a child's
imagination
you don't want to put a child into a box
and then give him a character
tailor-made for that box and say here
you go child this is your character you
can relate to him this is the one
assigned to you so you can relate to
this character specifically
instead you want a child to use his
imagination
and and and use that to engage with and
relate to the characters
for example right now the fictional
characters that resonate the most with
my three-year-old daughter are
Spider-Man and Elsa from Frozen
and that that doesn't mean she's gender
fluid half boy and half girl it means
that she's an imaginative toddler and
that's a good thing Biden's plans to
help struggling business owners in the
wake of coveted lockdowns were to
prioritize black latino Native American
and women to own businesses it goes
without saying that if the roles were
reversed if Biden had to you know said
that his plans were to prioritize white
male loan businesses there would have
been outrage well if you own a business
you can't rely on the government to bail
you out you need to take matters into
your own hands and Innovation refunds
can help you do just that if your
business has five or more employees and
managed to survive covet you could be
eligible to receive a payroll tax rebate
of up to twenty six thousand dollars
that's per employee through the employee
retention credit just go to
getrefunds.com Innovation refunds has
already helped clients claim over three
billion dollars in payroll tax refunds
through the ERC and they may be able to
help your business too this is not a
loan there's no payback it's a refund of
your taxes simple as that there's no
upfront charge either they don't get
paid until your business gets its refund
so don't let this opportunity pass you
by see if your business qualifies for RC
assistance in just eight minutes go to
getrefunds.com click on qualify me and
answer a few questions is payroll tax
refund is only available for a limited
amount of time don't miss out go to
getrefunds.com getrefunds.com
but that was only the first woke attack
launched against Blue a year later two
Australian academics published an
article talking uh taking aim at Bandit
the dad character noting a quote darker
side to this lovable character they
claim that Bandit quote never Strays far
from reductive stereotypes bemoaning the
fact that he is a quote likable roguish
male stuck between childhood and
adulthood whose disrespect of authority
in Rough and Ready masculinity reflects
Australia's emotional attachment to the
working class underdog
the writers also take Bandit to task for
incidents of alleged bullying because
the ways that he uh playfully teases his
children in the show he's bullying them
and they scold the cartoon dog for being
quote surprisingly conservative when it
comes to gender values
in other words as already established
the dad character is portrayed as normal
masculine funny
which is why he's so popular and
relatable with the audience and also why
uh leftist weirdo academics are so
concerned about him
fast forward another year to this past
week and we have the next woke assault
on a family of fictional cartoon dogs an
episode in season three titled exercise
opens with Bandit
stepping on a scale in the bathroom
and then he says oh man I need to do
some exercise
and that's the scene
it's a scene that I mean may seem
utterly uncontroversial and unremarkable
to you but that's because you're a
normal human being to the left however
the scene is problematic
and that's how it was described by this
alleged Child Development expert on Tick
Tock who has a PHD by the way and she
wants to explain why we should be very
concerned about this scene in Bluey
listen
we recently screwed up in a pretty big
way and it's made a lot of people angry
but basically there's a brand new
episode called exercise where at the
start Bandit Louie's dad grabbed his
belly I'll show you a picture here and
kind of just looks at it
and like goes to scale weighs himself
and goes ugh
I need to do exercise that in and of
itself is a really problematic narrative
to have on a children's television show
when we know that most girls by the time
they're nine think about dieting think
they're overweight and really have a
problem with body image already there's
a couple ways to solve this problem the
first one is that we're just not let the
kids watch the episode but
that's not really going to work because
kids are going to see this messaging
in many places throughout their lives so
it's actually better to use this episode
of a relatively safe children's
television show to start the discussion
about body image about how we treat our
body about not body positivity or body
negativity but body neutrality because
the truth is it doesn't matter what your
body looks like it matters how it feels
and that's the most important thing that
we need to teach our children
uh not really the point but that uh I
never had the Vegemite
stuff
but it could not look less appealing it
looks it basically looks like it's is it
like black tar and coffee grinds that
you
smear on your toast with butter
um body neutrality she says of course
telling Society to be neutral about
obesity it's like telling lifeguards to
practice drowning neutrality whether
somebody's swimming or drowning it's not
up for us to judge drowning is just just
as valid an experience as swimming who
are we to tell people whether they
should be at the surface of the water or
beneath it
just as we should draw no distinctions
between a physically fit person and a
person who is morbidly obese
sure the obese person is literally dying
in front of us
is killing themselves destroying their
bodies their skeletal structures their
internal organs
that's just how they've chosen to live
and express themselves and die certainly
we want to send the problematic message
that being healthy and living a long
life is somehow better than being
extremely fat and dying of a heart
attack when you're 42.
this anyway was the argument made by
leftist various leftists on tick tock
and in this case the first two attacks
fell flat this one actually resonated at
least it resonated with the ABC which
decided to cut that scene from the
episode
the issue this statement quote
the recent episode of blue we exercise
has been republished by the ABC
following the decision by the the makers
of the program the new version provides
families with the opportunity to manage
important conversations in their own way
as the home of Bluey and the ABC
supports the decision to re-edit the
program and we have updated the episode
on our platforms BBC Studios will use
this revised version for global
distribution and also support this
decision
lots of relief now children who watch
that episode of Bluey will not be
exposed to any objectionable content
encouraging them to engage in
inappropriate behavior such as you know
exercising
this is the last rules for uh Children's
Entertainment
that's the rule it cannot be normal
it cannot be wholesome
and it cannot encourage moral or
physical Improvement the last rule is
the most important to them
and as long as Bluey continues to
violate these rules it will remain a
Target they won't be satisfied until
Bluey is Rewritten as a show about
morbidly obese gay dogs with body
dysmorphia and clinical depression
that's that's what they want
and if the makers of the show ever
succumb to that pressure they'll be the
ones who are canceled but for now it is
blueys cancellers who are today canceled
I'll do it for this portion of shows
move our members block you can become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed